798 mètre carré réservé à la
restauration et aux ambiances musicales
du nom du bout du monde seront en
principe complètement modifiée au profit
de deux autres structures sur 513 mètres
carrés le promoteur le groupe soul
antilles guyane
sas a full service envisage la
réalisation d'une station service
mais aussi d'un fast food à cet
emplacement
le permis de construire délivré par la
mairie de ducos est contestée par les
membres de l'asso pamart aujourd'hui on
voit que le maire délivre juste avant
les élections un permis de construire
pour deux activités une activité de
restaurants et une activité de deux
stations d'essence alors que normalement
nous aurions dû avoir deux dalles testé
deux autorisations tous les deux
activités de prévoir que ses enfants un
scandale de la ville de ducos et que la
soupe à marseille jour sociaux cela
alors tout de suite depuis nous sommes
allés déjà en mairie nous n'avons pas pu
consulter le dossier parce que la mairie
est fermée mais comprenez bien que nous
allons porter ça devant le tribunal
gilbert mance et maire de la commune de
ducos s'étonne de cette nouvelle
mobilisation de la sopam art il avance
que ce nouveau permis de construire en
bonne et due forme a été accordé après
avis de l'état et les services
compétents
elle précise qu'il ne pouvait se poser à
un nouveau projet conduit par des jeunes
cg nord l'effet bella différemment
des divertissements et la carte sim ou
15 ans le projet qui met n'est pas jeune
part du groupe qu'il est le père des
motifs l'actuel exploitant de ce site
que nous avons pu joindre ce matin par
téléphone ne semble pas du tout inquiété
par ses futures modifications et ce
nouveau projet de station d'essence et
de fast food
il se pose pour l'instant à tout
commentaire mais précise que ce terrain
avait déjà fait l'objet de déclassement
durant la révision du plan local
d'urbanisme